inspiration is sometimes found in the
most unlikely places 95 year old Harvey
jerf walks nearly a mile around his
neighborhood twice a day every day
the Minnesota man is getting around with
a little help from his Flint friends
vladimir duthiers of our streaming
network cbsn shows us how Harvey's
perseverance keeps him and his neighbors
moving I think it's seven tenths of a
mile even though he's not as fast as he
used to be that's just fine for Harvey
jerf the 95 year old war War 2 veteran
and retired biology teacher has been
walking this subdivision for more than
65 years number 1 chair and the
neighbors have taken notice dotted along
his nearly mile-long route ever though
his chair after chair after chair as I
got older I stop and rest more often and
the neighbors have noticed
Harvey stopping hi and taking his breath
so then they've been putting out
different chairs and inviting me to sit
and take a rest hey Alex how are you
good to see you
he's a bit of a celebrity in Plymouth
Minnesota 4 miles outside Minneapolis
there's Harvey get a hug so that's
number 8 this is wonderful experience
and it's a social experience and I get
to know the neighbors when they get to
know me you been at 95 life is a way of
slowing down but for Harvey his walks
and his rest are a chance to keep the
pace steady my wife said years ago I
just I'm antsy I can't sit still these
days Harvey's on his own his wife Pat of
69 years suffered a stroke this past
summer and is recovering at an assisted
living facility this is my favorite
plush place to sit and rest it's the
walking that keeps Harvey going a nice
day and it's the connection with his
neighbors that might just motivate them
they say when they see Harvey go by
twice a day they figured they should get
harder to walk to himself for CBS this
morning
vladimir duthiers big thank you to our
CBS station in Minneapolis WCCO for
helping us
there Harvey stories me but America
ain't that America that's right
well done